hi I'm Lisa James doing here by tomorrow
Hussein we're here at gamescom 2015 just
painted the xbox media briefing and now
with the ugly showcase where we're
getting to see some of the games Tom
what he displayed I just play super hot
was it super hot so hot it was really
good to us it's a game that has its
origins in a browser kind of experience
it's really really cool concept the way
it's first-person shooter and time only
progresses when you move so for example
if you fire a bullet the bullet doesn't
leave your chamber and travel across a
room until you start the movie so it's
actually more of a puzzle game than a
first-class issue of the type of
traditional type of experience so you're
doing things like most of the puzzles
are built around people bursting into a
room you're trying to figure out where
they're going to go try and look at
their body and figure out the momentum
where they're traveling how the body is
moving and try and place a bullet in
front of them and then move to let you
all kind of collide together it's really
really interesting I think you can
actually still play the game on Donna
browser well I Xbox one they've clearly
progressed the kind of design maybe as
the demo went along the
puzzles were becoming more and more
elaborate I reached the point where i
was in one that was really difficult and
I had to just give up on it was like in
a bar with a and you're throwing objects
to disarm people and then grabbing their
guns as it was falling and then trying
to shoot a guy with shot line in this
kind of thing it gets really really
elaborate wait it's interesting to have
to really think about some first person
to experience like think about every
bully that you're firing instead of
being like in something like Call of
Duty where you just firing an entire
clips randomly into it into enemies so
yeah really really fun game super nice
visual style just you know you're white
and red it remind me a little bit of
Mirror's Edge actually just like they
you know everything is white and there's
no distractions really everything that
you know even placed for a perfect
exactly I think it's because they really
need to make sure that you can see every
threat coming towards so the enemies are
big and red and they're they're rendered
in glass so when you shoot them like the
chip away at them and all the bullets
have trails so you know where they're
coming from so it's basically trying to
kill you in on your surroundings so you
know exactly what to do where the threat
is coming from really cool puzzle game
more than anything so more from super
hot and all the other I do xbox games on
xbox one games coming out this year and
next make sure you stay tuned to games
you